Oui c’est à quel sujet?
Bah cette armure, cette armure de merde pour commencer.
Bon déjà on est en blanc, c’est hyper grillé. A la limite un taupe quoi, un beige ou…
Très bien...
Nan, attends, attends c’est pas fini.
Non parce qu’on se fait quand même chier à porter tout cet attirail,
et au premier coup de blaster, on est mort!
Autre chose?
Oui! Ce casque!
Mes yeux, mes yeux là ils sont à ce niveau là hein!
Et la visière est dix centimètre au-dessus donc on arrive à tirer sur personne!
Bon on va faire quelque chose, on va essayer d’améliorer les casques.
Oui, euh... ce serait au sujet de la seule meuf que j’ai croisé de ma vie.
Hein hein, la princesse Leia ?
Oui, elle est bonne hein?!
Euh, ouais.
Et en plus d’être bonne, elle est drôle, charismatique, intelligente, indépendante, euh...
Elle est parfaite.
C’est pas une plainte ça!
Si, elle est parfaite, et c’est ma sœur putain!
La seule meuf que je pouvais me taper dans toute la galaxie, c’est ma sœur!
Nan mais monsieur Fett vous êtes le chasseur de prime le plus classe de la galaxie.
Mmh, bah justement.
Donc ça vous pose un problème d’être super stylé et super badass.
Oui, je suis super stylé et super badass mais j’ai la mort la plus ridicule de l’histoire.
Ouais j’avoue qu’ils ne font même pas exprès de vous tuer.
Et le cri que je pousse quand je meurs...
Ridicule.
Venez on fait comme si j’étais pas vraiment mort!
Bah, si vous voulez j’ai reçu des propales,
euh, mais bon ça n’a pas été validé, donc non déso.
Sérieux?
J’ai dit déso.
Seigneur Vador.
C’est ma cape elle me gêne.
Euh, enlevez-la.
Pas con.
Voilà nan mais je m’énerve mais c’est un vrai problème pour viser.
Moi j’ai un collègue par exemple qui a réussi une fois à toucher une rebelle à l’épaule,
bah après il s’est fait tirer dessus, il est tombé, direct.
Direct ouais.
Parce que les armures sont en plastique. Regardez.
C’est de la merde.
Bonjour.
Je connais pas mes parents.
Mmh mmh.
Ôtez moi d’un doute. Vous allez pas me faire le coup de...
«En fait mon père c’est Luke S…»
Vous voyez cette personne extrêmement sexy là?
Ah elle est… Nan nan c’est une belle plante.
C’est ma sœur. C’est elle ma sœur!
Ok !
C’est joli ça, c’est quoi?
Un stylo quatre couleurs. Les quatre couleurs primaires.
Vous êtes fier?
Oui.
Mais euh... J’aurai moins la classe sans?
Ah!
Mais vous êtes bien aussi comme ça.
Je sais pas.
Alors si je puis me pe…
Je peux en caser une?
C’est incroyable!
Putain!
Mais tout le monde se fout de notre gueule.
On s’est fait victimiser par les Ewoks steuplait!
Bon écoutez, j’ai demandé à ce qu’on revoit la copie pour les armures et les casques. Donc maintenant s’il vous plaît, un peu de patience!
C’est ça, allez.
Ah ça fait une belle courbe au niveau de... De la fesse.
Quoi?
Y a rien à retoucher.
Laissez moi deviner. Vous aussi vous allez vous plaindre qu’on ne vous comprend pas?
C’est lui?
Je vous ai dit que je connaissais pas mes parents?
Tututu, le stylo!
Donc vous la kiffez un peu quand même...
Qu’est-ce que vous avez ressenti quand vous l’avez embrassé sur la…?
On parle d’inceste.
C’est ma sœur!
Allez la porte.
Est-ce qu’on pourrait parler de mon père avec son prénom de gitan là?
Ah d’accord.
Bon! Bah je vais niquer ma mère alors!
Voilà!
Nikel!
Bah les yeux sont toujours là quoi...
Genre pas en face quoi.
Ouais, c’est chiant là quand même.
Mais y a un mieux malgré tout.
Ouais nan mais esthétiquement il y a un mieux, c’est vrai!
Clairement!
Mais bon.
Bien, vous pouvez disposer!
Y a eu changement au niveau du boule là hein!
C’est pas la même chose, c’est pas aussi galbé!
Franck, t’a changé quelque chose au niveau du, du boule là, hein ouais?
Oui oui j’ai pris quelques libertés oui.
Ouais bah c’est pas bon!
Désolé.
Ah putain ça, ça me saoule.
Ces cons ils nous saoulent toute la journée.
Il n’y a que toi qui me comprends.